Mac Miller
Mac restera dans les mémoires comme l'un des
artistes les plus prolifiques de cette génération.
Je ne sais pas si j'ai déjà perdu quelqu'un
dont j'étais si proche et qui était mon
ami. J'aurais juste aimé passer plus de temps avec
lui.
[Musique]
merci suggestions
quelle est l'urgence comment pouvons-nous vous aider
êtes-vous là avec lui maintenant, quelle est
la dernière fois que vous l'avez vu ou lui avez parlé
hier s'il vous plaît
pouvez-vous le réveiller vous les avez trouvés sur
le lit par terre
bonjour monsieur  Univers victime
ne mélange pas ça avec ces conneries j'espère
ne pas rejoindre le Club 27
bienvenue James McCormick
Photographies de Pittsburgh ou de Pennsylvanie
tu n'arrêtes pas le
centre d'attention type d'enfant s'il
était dans une pièce c'était presque impossible
qu'il  n'essayait pas de capturer la
pièce, tu sais, il faisait toujours des blagues, il
essayait d'être, tu sais, la vie de
la fête est en quelque sorte
[Musique]
étrangère [
Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
nous, cette musique nous ressemblait un peu  cela
représentait ce que font généralement les enfants de cet âge, c'est-à-dire
fumer
beaucoup d'herbe en essayant de s'amuser avec
vous savez, le sexe opposé essayant de
sortir de l'œil vigilant des
autorités, des parents ou des enseignants, euh, de la
police, j'étais juste un enfant en train de mettre  de la musique sur
Internet, puis mes fans sont
devenus fous et ce n'est que lorsque mes fans
étaient si indéniables que les gens ont vraiment
commencé à se concentrer sur qui j'étais,
alors j'ai dû remercier mes fans pour tout
parce que vous savez si c'était le cas.  pas pour que les gens
me soutiennent, je ne ferais rien
ouais, il a une base de fans assez active, je
pense qu'il était conscient de l'
élément racial qui était comme ouais, je suis un
mec blanc qui rappe et j'ai beaucoup
de blanc  des fans qui m'aiment juste parce que
je suis comme le mec blanc qui rappe, vous
savez,
Donald Trump,
un jeune rappeur nommé Matt Miller
a fait une chanson intitulée Donald Trump et on vient de me
dire qu'elle a frappé plus de 54 millions de personnes, il
n'était pas
pour Donald Trump  que les gens savent aujourd'hui qu'il
aimait juste tweeter des choses folles
54 millions de personnes je veux de l'argent Matt
me donne de l'argent j'ai droit à 25 au
moins
c'était une sorte d'attaque plus pointue
pas nécessairement contre sa musique mais aussi
contre lui  lui-même, je pense qu'il en a été
assez profondément affecté ouais
oh [
Musique]
ok
différentes drogues la dépression la musique était le
moyen pour lui de
sortir ces choses
[Musique]
au fur et à mesure que sa carrière progresse, le son de
sa musique change beaucoup certains de ses
la musique est des chansons très introspectives qui
parlent presque de
questions existentielles sur ce que signifie même
être en vie et je ne sens même pas mes jambes je suis
paraplégique ce que je veux
je me demande mes démons Karen Myers s'est
mariée avec Jésus mort-né, ils  J'ai dû
déterrer mon fœtus alors maintenant le diable veut
me déchirer en morceaux beaucoup de ses paroles
ressemblent beaucoup à des
journaux intimes littéraux. Il dit
tout ce que vous ressentez un jour donné où
vous entrez et vous  faites une chanson à ce sujet
et puis vous passez à autre chose et ensuite vous
passez au lendemain
[Musique]
merci,
surpris
[Musique]
il a embrassé dans la vidéo qui était comme un
baiser non scénarisé avance rapide de quelques années
Mac était allé en cure de désintoxication  Ariana est
allée lui rendre visite dans une cure de désintoxication, elle est devenue
juste quelqu'un avec qui il était très proche
peu de temps après, vous savez, ils ont
eu
des albums romantiques, une femme divine dit
[Musique]
puis il était à peu près sobre tout au long de
cette relation et puis vous savez petit
à petit  un peu,
tu sais, il tombait en quelque sorte du
wagon
euh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a pris une pilule qu'il pensait être tu
sais une chose et ça a fini par en être une
autre, en gros tu connais les fausses pilules
et s'il y a quelque chose à faire
ce qu'il faut retenir, c'est que les gens devraient savoir
que s'ils consomment des pilules d'opioïdes du marché noir,
ils jouent à la roulette russe.
Ariana Grande
[Musique]
qu'il serait
heureux du soutien qu'il a reçu de
ses fans
[Applaudissements]
nous avons fait nos vies  tellement différent
je vais finir je vais finir avec
quelque chose que tu ne voudras probablement pas
entendre
oh
alors ils ont finalement attrapé l'enfoiré
qui leur a vendu la drogue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] les
cercles sont
bonnes nouvelles
non, ils ne le font pas  je t'aime quand j'ai fini
les vidéos
[Musique]